[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What is this?
God, I love this
show, I love this job.
-Gets bigger and
bigger every year.
-We're gonna rock the boat.
[EXPLOSION]
-And that's my Final Judgment.
[SPLASH]
-What does the ideal body
look like around the world?
-It's "Pop Trigger" time!
Welcome to "What the Flick?!"
-I finished watching it, and
I thought, oh, that was nice.
-Welcome to "Nerd Alert" at CES.
-Welcome back to another
FIFA What-If challenge.
-We want to completely
revitalize the Democratic Party
and make it a party
of the people.
-What's happening to
millennials, the demographic
that's most impacted by this?
-[BLEEP] yeah!
-TYT!
TYT!
-We're not The Young Turks,
you're The Young Turks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JOE: Have a seat.
CENK UYGUR: Thank you, guys.
That was very nice.
JOE: Cenk, welcome to Google.
Welcome to Chicago.
CENK UYGUR: Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
We're not Google, you're Google.
JOE: So tell me, you just
shared a story with me
when you flew in
here to Chicago.
How big is TYT?
5 billion views.
We've just seen it.
CENK UYGUR: Yeah, so it's
one thing to see the numbers,
and people throw around
numbers, et cetera.
It's another thing to
see it in real life.
So this morning,
I'm getting a cab
from the hotel to come here.
And the guy in the cab
says to me, oh my god!
I just saw you this morning!
I was just watching you!
And he said, this is
like out of a movie.
But the cool part of that
story is that he then
explained to me that he was
making breakfast for his son,
and that they now have
a morning ritual where
they flip around YouTube,
and they watch it together.
So it's a whole new world.
In the old days,
that would have been
local news, or that would have
been "Good Morning America."
Now, they probably don't
even know what that is.
And it used to be people
under the age of 25
had no idea about old media.
Now, I think, it's under
the age of 35 have no idea.
When I go to talk to young
audiences, and I ask them,
does anyone know who's
the primetime news
anchor of ABC, CBS, or NBC?
None of them know.
None of them.
JOE: Yeah.
So yeah, today, we want to talk
a bit about your history, who
you are, so that people get
an idea what formed you.
And then we will talk a
bit about The Young Turks,
who The Young Turks
are, what defines you,
really, as a news program.
And also, in particular,
about the change
we're seeing in
the news landscape,
in the media landscape in
general, fueled by technology
and particularly the internet.
And in the end, a bit
of the current landscape
we're seeing with the elections.
Cool?
CENK UYGUR: Yeah.
JOE: So, Cenk, I did a bit
of research, and obviously,
Wikipedia, a very trusted
source of everyone
in the millennial
landscape here.
You moved to the US with your
parents when you were eight.
CENK UYGUR: That's right.
JOE: Can you tell us a
bit of your background?
CENK UYGUR: Sure.
So we're in the best of times,
we're in the worst of times.
And the worst of
times is easy to see.
You see the terrorism,
you see Donald Trump.
But we forget the best of times.
So let me give you
some context there.
In 1820, the average life
expectancy was 35 years old.
So I'd have been
long dead by now.
And 1820's not that long ago,
just a couple hundred years.
And the reason I
bring that up is
because my dad grew
up as an olive farmer
in southeastern Turkey.
And one of the
revolutions people
don't talk about is
public education.
So he wound up getting
public education all the way
through college.
He earned his way, and got
a free public education
in Istanbul, and became
a mechanical engineer.
Otherwise, we'd have never
gotten off that farm.
Right now, I'd be an olive
farmer in southeastern Turkey,
getting shelled by ISIS.
So we have made a tremendous
amount of progress.
And so my dad got to build
a business in Turkey.
He sold it.
He came here.
And I remember when I came
here, and I was eight years old,
because I had lived
in a big city,
in Istanbul-- lots of
concrete, tall buildings--
and then we moved to the
suburbs of New Jersey,
and I thought that was nirvana.
I was like, oh my god, look at
this utopia called New Jersey.
There's grass everywhere.
I'm like, this giant house.
I'm like, how many
families are living here?
They're like, no, just us.
I'm like, this is amazing!
I love America!
So that's how we came over.
And then I wound up
getting a decent education,
and off we go.
And so all that
was made possible
by that earlier revolution.
JOE: OK.
And you are very liberal, like
center to very to the left.
But I also heard that you
have been quite conservative
in the past.
What has really changed you?
CENK UYGUR: Yeah, so
two things have changed.
Some of my views have
changed a little bit.
But I think that, actually,
Washington has changed more.
I think a lot of my views are
similar to what they were when
I was growing up as a
so-called liberal Republican
in New Jersey.
Of course, that just
doesn't exist anymore.
There are no liberal
Republicans left.
But there were when
I was growing up.
And so I'm considered way
left, I guess, in America.
I bet in Europe,
I'd be considered
right down the middle.
I look at Jeremy Corbyn,
and I like his revolution.
I look at some of his
views, and I go, oh,
that's a little left,
that's a little left.
I'm going to do a town
hall at YouTube Space LA
this Friday with Jill Stein.
And John Oliver just quoted
one of my earlier interviews
with her in his show on Sunday.
And in that section,
we're talking
about how she's going to
get rid of all student debt.
And I was like, oh, that's
a little left, that's
a little left.
So what changed?
One, my eyes got open to the
marketing of the Republicans.
They're great at marketing.
So they'll say, OK, we
want to balance the budget.
Really?
You got a funny
way of showing it.
The last Republican
president to leave office
with a balanced budget
was Dwight Eisenhower,
who, by the way,
now would be too
liberal for the
Democratic Party.
So the entire
spectrum has changed.
They're like, oh my
god, we hate amnesty.
Who did amnesty?
Ronald Reagan.
Flat out amnesty.
And so I think
there's some chance
that Reagan, in some
of his positions,
would be considered too
liberal for the Democrats, let
alone the Republicans.
So there's been this
massive rightward shift,
But in the political
landscape in Washington,
not in the country.
If you do polling
in the country,
America is solidly progressive
on almost every single issue--
immigration, taxes, social
security, you name it.
And then, of course,
the Iraq War.
Al Gore was the first
Democrat I ever voted for.
I watched the debates.
I have eyes.
And I was like, the one guy is
way smarter than the other guy.
And then once Bush got into
office, and he's like, oh,
we're going to Iraq.
I'm like, what?
I don't get it.
They didn't attack us.
Why are people missing
the big picture of they
did not attack us?
And so I was off that
crazy train at that point.
And then they started
torturing people,
and that's not what
I signed up for.
So that was a super easy
decision by that time.
JOE: OK.
Let's switch gears a bit and
talk about The Young Turks.
So it started out
as a radio show,
and now you're at a stage where
you have 5 billion, right?
CENK UYGUR: That's right.
JOE: 5 billion views and
8 million subscribers
across the network.
Can you tell us what, the
step was from a radio show
to actually an
online video show?
CENK UYGUR: So there's a
couple aspects to that.
First, I always wanted to do
online video, even way before I
started the radio show.
So back in '98, I wrote
an email to my friends,
and I said, online video
is going to take off,
and it is going to
merge/replace TV.
And they're like,
oh, you're crazy.
That will never happen.
And I'm like, no, I'm
positive it's going to happen.
And so at the time that we
started The Young Turks,
it was 2002.
We were as leading edge as we
could be within our resources.
So we were the first
original talk show
for Sirius satellite radio.
So we started that
in my living room
because I had no resources.
We were in a one-bedroom
apartment off of Sunset in LA.
And we bought a couple of
mics and a radio thing,
and got going.
And then at the end of '05,
I'm at a diner with a friend
of mine, Jim Gilliam,
who's a genius guy,
eventually started
NationBuilder.
And I said, look,
Jim, I've been wanting
to do online radio
since back in '98,
way before I started
The Young Turks.
He said, OK, great,
let's do it tomorrow.
And I said, what do you
mean "let's do it tomorrow"?
He's like, I know how to do it.
He's like, you buy the
cameras, I'll come set it up.
And we did.
And we're like, OK.
And Jim's like, I love
giving you advice.
You're the only one who
actually acts on it.
People say they want advice,
they don't want advice.
They just want affirmation.
I'm like, no,
that's a good idea.
I'm doing it right now.
And we didn't know
what we were doing.
We got a little
place on Wilshire.
It was an office building.
We didn't know you
needed high ceilings.
We didn't know anything
about lighting.
So we got this
tiny little office,
and we put a wooden table in the
front, giant radio microphones
that covered up our face.
And we got started,
the lights in our head.
And then you know what happened?
One, YouTube happened.
And two, the audience happened.
So it was not just that
we gained the audience.
It was that the
audience-- that's
why I said it in that video,
we're not The Young Turks,
you're The Young Turks.
We formed a symbiotic
relationship
where they were
part of the show.
First suggestion they had for
us was move the goddamn mics.
They're like, we don't
care about you and Ben,
but Jill is gorgeous.
Move the mic.
Move the mic, all right?
And then they would
literally send in, hey,
this is the lav mic
you need to buy.
It goes on your jacket.
And here are the specs on it.
Some other guy came
in with TriCaster,
like an old school
TriCaster we needed.
He's like, here, just take it.
And we're like,
oh, that's awesome.
Now we can switch the cameras.
It doesn't have
to be one camera.
And so we just built it
together with the audience.
And I think, even more to the
central point of your question,
we gave them an alternative.
And when we were on the radio
but also in online video,
people would most often say
to us in the YouTube comments,
and the emails, and
later, in Twitter, you
are a voice in the wilderness.
I thought I was alone.
And there was a mom
in North Carolina who
would put her kid in the car
and drive around, and around,
and around to listen to us
back when we were on the radio.
Because she's like, I couldn't
believe what I was hearing.
I'm like, that's right.
That's why there's no
one else saying that.
That's right.
And so one part of it
was that nobody was doing
anything that was progressive.
If you just look at that
from a business perspective,
that's mental.
You're leaving 50%--
I would argue 60%--
of the market
completely untapped.
What kind of business
people are you?
JOE: Why do you think
that is actually the case?
CENK UYGUR: Which leads
to the second point,
which gets to your question.
I think the bigger
part of it is not
so much that we're progressive,
but that we were doing it
from an outsider perspective,
and almost everyone else
was doing it from an
insider perspective.
News.
So they have the big
shiny studios on CNN.
And they have all these people
who worked in government,
and was a spokesperson for this
and a spokesperson for that.
That's not the answer.
That's the problem.
So you're giving everybody
an insider perspective.
And the guy sitting at home in
Wichita, he's not an insider,
he's an outsider.
He's part of the Rebel Alliance.
He doesn't want to be part
of your Death Star, right?
JOE: Love it.
CENK UYGUR: So that actually
gives us 98% of the audience.
And I'm being kind to
them, leaving them 2%.
So I think that's
what resonated.
And the reason why
no one else does
it is because in the old days,
if you wanted to set up a media
company, especially
in television,
you needed to be a
multibillion dollar company.
You needed all that
infrastructure.
You needed distribution.
You needed to buy
your way into it.
And when you're a
multibillion dollar company,
you ain't the Rebel Alliance,
you're the Death Star.
And so luckily, the internet has
changed that dynamic completely
because it has now empowered
many Rebel Alliances
and flipped the paradigm.
But for old media,
they couldn't get out
of their insider perspective
because it just trickled down
from the top all the way down
to the anchors, what I call,
not news anchors,
but news actors.
They're hired to read
a script, pre-approved.
And it comes all the way
down from management.
Not that the management
writes their scripts.
It doesn't work that way.
But management
hires the producers,
who hires the anchors, who
all have the same perspective.
So that's why they
couldn't do it.
They couldn't do it
even if they wanted to.
JOE: Yeah, and for people
who don't know The Young
Turks-- like me, for example,
I moved to the US a year ago,
and that's how I came
across your channel--
how would you really
define The Young Turks
and what you do on your
channel and particularly
the main channel?
CENK UYGUR: Yeah, so we want
to be a digital campfire
for the world.
So in the old days, the one
good thing was we had campfires.
So we had "Seinfeld."
Everybody would
watch "Seinfeld,"
and everybody would
talk about "Seinfeld."
We had the Super Bowl.
Super Bowl's still around.
And we would have
some news programs
that everybody watched,
maybe "Good Morning America"
or "Today Show," et cetera.
Use these water coolers,
campfires, however you
want to call it.
I want to recreate that
for the digital age.
And so I think
The Young Turks is
where people come to
find out about the news,
discuss the news.
And it's not just us
discussing it, which we do,
but it's also in the comments.
That's why we're among
the top YouTube channels
on number of comments per video.
I think we were
at 14-- now, we're
at 1,600 comments per video.
And the same is true
across all the platforms.
Because that's where people
gather to discuss that news.
So it's about news, and I want
to be the global news leader.
And I think we're
going to replace CNN,
and I think we're going
to do that, honestly,
relatively easily.
But it's not just
about the news.
It's about a discussion about
what is happening in the world
today, so whatever
is relevant to you.
So the old school way
of thinking of news
is, OK, hardcore
politics, yada yada.
The new way of thinking about
it is whatever is news to you.
So whether it's
entertainment, sports, or it
could be more granular too.
So we want to go global, but
we also want to go local.
JOE: Yeah.
And I think these big
news corporations,
they profit from their
access and their resources.
But I've seen, now, Jill Stein,
Bernie Sanders on your channel.
You have Jordan Chariton,
a guy outside in the field,
basically.
How do you see the
future playing out
for TYT, especially on
that access and resources
perspective?
Because I think
that's a big part.
CENK UYGUR: Yeah.
Well, that's our biggest
challenge because-- it's funny.
In the valley, Silicon
Valley, they always
say, oh, they want disruptors.
But when they see
a real disruptor,
they get a little
freaked out by it.
Like They want a disruptor
that's like the same thing
they've always seen-- a
young guy out of Stanford,
played in a jazz
band, yada yada.
That's not a disruptor.
So when we go shake their
house a little bit, and we say,
no, no, we're going to
pulverize the news business
as you know it.
This was new media.
And we came up organically.
And we came up
with the audience.
And here's our plan for
having more Jordan Charitons
in the field.
So that's our investigative
reporter, field reporter,
he's done a great, great job.
Yesterday, I was
in Seattle doing
a TV show, Young
Turks on Fusion,
talked to about 200 people in
the audience after the show.
They were like, oh, give us more
of that, give us more of that.
And I want to.
So when you go to
some investors,
it makes them a
little uncomfortable.
Oh, Bernie Sanders?
Ugh, he'd raise my taxes.
Damn straight he would.
And so that's a dynamic
we've gotta deal with.
It's not easy.
So we have a subscription model.
We have, obviously,
ads on YouTube.
We've got YouTube Red.
Got ads on other platforms.
And we cobble this thing
together, and we keep it going.
But I think that in order to
get those 10 reporters instead
of just 1, and really
get out there and cover
things more dynamically, we're
going to need more resources.
And I think that if
we got around the size
of normal digital media
companies, watch out.
They'd have almost no
chance of stopping us.
We duct taped this thing
all the way to here.
If you guys knew how little
money was in The Young Turks,
it is astounding.
How in the world did we beat CNN
with three rolls of duct tape?
And so I think that we're
the most efficient company,
probably, in digital media.
And so if we got a real
round, we'd clean up.
JOE: And what are
your plans to do that?
How do you break out of
this small business world
and into getting the
message out further?
CENK UYGUR: Yeah, so
resources are real.
There's two ways to do it, and
it's a combination of that.
So number one, we could do this
round that I'm talking about.
If you're at home, you might
not know what I'm saying,
but I think a lot of
people in this room do.
But the way that things
work in the new day and age
is you go raise big
amounts of money,
and that's your
resources to grow.
And then you get to-- well,
we would get to profitability.
A lot of other people just exit.
But that's a whole
nother conversation.
But we're built to last.
So that allows you to
build in a sustainable way,
so you've got more
reporters, more audience,
and you create a virtuous cycle.
And we were just
having a conversation
internally over the last
couple of weeks on this.
And I think that somebody out
there or several people out
there are going to go look and
go, oh, yeah, that makes sense.
I gotta get in on that.
And so that will
very likely happen.
But the other way
is just organically,
like we've been doing it for
14 years and 10 years online.
And so the subscription
model is what
allowed us to hire
Jordan, which allowed
us to break so many
stories in this news cycle.
The subscription
model has allowed
us to add more shows, including
"Aggressive Progressive."
They thought I wasn't
progressive enough,
so they wanted more
aggressive progressives.
And we started a whole
show called that.
And so the more that
people pay $10 a month,
the more we can give them.
And that's what we do.
We just take the
money, and we grow it,
we grow it, more
reporting, more shows.
JOE: Yeah.
Let's focus a bit
more on that part,
especially on the
independent media part.
Because that's how you
really differentiate yourself
from CNN, MSNBC,
Fox News, et cetera,
because you're not
held-- you don't
have any huge investors that
basically tell you what to do.
So from that
perspective, what do you
think are the advantages?
And what are you
really struggling
with as an independent media?
CENK UYGUR: Yeah,
so the struggle
is what you would expect.
Here, let me make
it real for you
guys, a concrete
example that gives you
a sense of what it means to
be at a resource disadvantage.
So everybody keeps coming to
us and saying, why aren't you
guys on Snapchat?
Now, not in this
building, they're not.
Well, OK, yeah,
CNN's on Snapchat,
and XYZ's on Snapchat.
Well, Snapchat demands
original programming,
and it's structured to
their specific platform.
And I've done research,
and other companies
have, literally, 30-person
teams for their Snapchats.
Well, yes, CNN can afford
to throw away millions
upon millions upon millions
of dollars every year
trying to build some
sort of audience
on Snapchat, which is, by
the way, never going to work.
Which 24-year-old or
12-year-old is like, oh,
everybody, quiet, quiet,
Wolf is on, right?
But they can throw
a 30-person team
at it, which is a giant
amount of resources.
I don't have a 30-person team.
That's half my company.
Would I love to be on
all those platforms?
Yes.
But those are the things that
we've gotta struggle with.
And they've got bureaus all
over the world, and we will too,
but it takes us more
time to get there.
But the advantage is
I'm not encumbered
by all of their
monumental disadvantages.
They can't turn the damn ship.
What are their disadvantages?
They're reading from a
prompter, everybody knows it.
Even if they don't know it,
they feel it in their gut.
Why is that guy not talking
to me like a human being?
Why are they all robots?
So I remember watching this
local news in Louisiana
when I was down there
a bunch of years ago,
and she talked like this.
And you guys will all
recognize it from local news.
The number of ambulances
have doubled, but so
have the number of accidents.
Who talks like that?
Why did they convince
themselves that that's
the way that a
"professional" should talk?
Maybe a professional robot,
but I wouldn't have even
programmed it that way.
So they're stuck on the scripts,
and they can't get off of it.
That's so inauthentic.
You guys know that's never
going to work online.
They're stuck on access.
Oh my god, I need to get
Governor Kasich on my show
and Senator [INAUDIBLE].
No, you don't.
They're super boring.
And the audience does
not believe them,
does not trust them.
I remember when I
was at MSNBC, one
of the stylistic points
they had for me was act more
like a senator.
I was like, why?
Why would you act
more like a senator?
They're the dullest
people in the world.
Nobody's going to watch that.
And so when they're
stuck on access,
they're stuck on their
insider perspective,
they're stuck on
their prompters.
And they're like, well,
OK-- I finally got--
and they fought me on this
in the beginning at MSNBC,
and they did it even more
so after I left-- sometimes,
the anchors are now allowed
to take off their tie.
Ooh.
That's rearranging the
chairs on the Titanic.
So they see the iceberg, they
know what their audience-- you
guys know, right?
The average audience, the
median age of the CNN viewer
is 64 years old.
At Fox, it's 68.
At Bill O'Reilly, it's 72.
Pfft.
JOE: And at TYT?
CENK UYGUR: At TYT, we're
70% 18 to 34-year-olds, 70%.
They are doomed.
They have no chance against us.
I don't know if you guys have
read "David and Goliath,"
the Malcolm Gladwell book.
And he flips it on its head,
and he's absolutely right.
It's not that, oh, David
the underdog beat Goliath.
No, David was the favorite.
He had a slingshot.
He could just fire
from a distant.
Boom!
Goliath had no chance.
How the hell is he
going to reach him?
He's got a slingshot.
It's like a gun.
He's like, oh, yeah,
I have a big sword.
Boom!
Like Indiana Jones, right?
So we have a slingshot
called the internet.
They're never going to beat us.
They have no chance.
JOE: Yeah, actually, that's
a good segue to my next point
there.
We talked about how the
media landscape has changed,
but no question, the
internet and technology
has enabled that.
How do you think, also, the
news consumption of, especially,
the millennials has changed
the consumption piece of it?
CENK UYGUR: Yeah.
So I think the millennials
are consuming news
in a lot of different ways.
So let's keep it real.
They're also consuming
it in small snippets,
so whether it's on Facebook,
Snapchat, or on YouTube.
There's the memes, which, oy--
please double check the memes.
Memes are not journalism.
And there's some
good ones out there.
We've used some
from time to time.
But that's not a thing.
That's not a fact.
And how many Republican memes
have an asterisk and then
a link to the article?
None.
So anyway, but then there's like
the quick 30 second thing, hey,
here's what happened today.
Nothing wrong with that.
That's the way that
people consume news.
And then if they want a
little bit of analysis,
they come to us, or
commentary, or just really,
as I said before, discussion.
And it's as old as time.
When I was growing up, I used
to listen to Howard Stern.
And it's in the morning.
It's radio in the morning.
I already know the news.
I was a kid who cared
about the world.
So I had already listened
to Peter Jennings,
and I knew what the news was.
I went to Howard
because I can't wait
to see what Howard's
going to say about it.
I didn't care about
the rest of his show.
I mean, lesbians are fine.
But all the other
characters and stuff
like that actually annoyed me.
I was like, just get
to the news already.
And him and Robin would do the
news, and it was a campfire.
I was in Scotland, and
we were touring castles.
I love Scotland.
I love castles.
And I was really
interested to see they
had seven jobs at
the castle-- the guy
that protected the
castle, and the guy
who ruled the
castle, and the cook,
all these things you'd expect.
But one of the seven
was storyteller.
It's as old as time.
Because they needed
a storyteller.
They needed
entertainment, otherwise,
they're going to lose their
mind inside that castle.
So we're the storytellers
for the internet.
JOE: And we're in
a castle right now.
CENK UYGUR: Yeah, we
are at Google fortress.
It was hard to get in.
JOE: Yeah, so you
mentioned it-- Facebook,
Twitter, YouTube-- they all
accelerate the speed in what
news flows and gets shared.
Mobile devices get cheaper and
cheaper and more widespread.
Internet access
across the world.
How do you see this
space, this landscape,
of technology and news develop
in the next 5 to 10 years?
Now that everyone has access
not only to information,
but also can spread the news,
and create actually content,
and it's basically democratized.
CENK UYGUR: Yeah, so
I'm looking forward
to how we can
democratize our reporting
and our hosting even
more than we already do.
We have this program
called TYT Next where we
do auditions from time to time.
We're going to start
a new show, let's say
it's an entertainment show,
we bring in a ton of people
like anybody would,
and we go through them.
But we also find people
from our audience.
Now our second largest
channel is "Think Tank,"
and the host and
executive producer of that
is John Iadarola.
He was a kid at the
University of Texas
who was sending in videos to us.
We're like, he's pretty good.
And we had him come in,
work as an intern, then
a producer, then a host.
And then he took over
one of the channels
and made it the second largest
channel on the network.
I believe in that.
I think there's a great
resource of talent
all across the country,
all across the globe.
TYT Next has
struggled a little bit
because lack of resources-- I
need curators, I need editors.
So it's not the hosting
that's the issue at all.
A bunch of great
tapes were sent in,
but we've got to have the
manpower to curate all that,
get it up on the air.
So people are always
talking about, hey, I
got phones wherever I am.
I could just record it.
Great.
I want you to do that.
And they will do that.
And we will air it
on The Young Turks.
But I need editors.
I need curators.
I need to set up
the infrastructure
to make that happen.
So just being realistic about
how we're going to get there.
But again, I'd rather
be us than them
when you look at-- to the
core of your question--
how is news consumed?
Right now, nobody watches
the primetime news.
There's still
70-year-olds, and that's
why they've got 7 million
people left watching those
that are left over and such.
But even my dad is 78,
and I said, but, Dad,
every night, you used
to come home and watch
Peter Jennings, Tom Brokaw.
Why don't you do that anymore?
He's like, why I watch them?
I already got news online.
And it's true.
Why would you have
them regurgitate
the news you already read?
So that is a hopeless model.
And I was flying
in this morning,
and I'm sitting next to a guy,
and he's in his 60s, I guess.
And as people are coming onto
the plane, they're like, hey,
Cenk.
Hey, Young Turks.
Hey, I love the show.
I watch the show.
And after, I don't know
however many of these guys
do it, he turns around to
me and goes, who are you?
Because he doesn't know
it from his perspective,
but all those guys on
that plane are never
going to watch-- by the
way, the correct answer
is David Muir on ABC News.
David Muir?
Who's going to watch David Muir?
Nobody, the answer is
nobody, in 5 to 10 years.
Nobody.
So I think they're going
to shut some stuff down.
And by the way, now
I'm getting really
inside baseball on
the financials here,
but if you look at
CNN's financials,
1/3 of their revenue
comes from advertising.
2/3 comes from the cable
bundle, the subscription.
And every year, that goes down,
for the moment being, about 4%
a year.
It's going to speed up
to about 10% a year.
Now if 2/3 of your revenue is
getting watered down like that,
and you've built a giant Death
Star that costs a gazillion
dollars, well, you can't
afford that Death Star anymore.
So I don't know what happens
to CNN 10 years from now.
I know what happens to MSNBC.
That's hopeless.
They're goners.
Fox News is in much better
shape because at least they
know who their audience is, and
they can serve that audience.
CNN is going to be
drifting in space, kind
of like Sandra Bullock
in "Gravity," like, oh,
just doing circles.
But at some point,
I think they're
going to literally have to shut
down the old way they do news.
JOE: OK.
Are you looking forward to
the new Star Wars movie?
CENK UYGUR: Apparently.
A lot of references.
JOE: We have 10 more
minutes before we open it up
to the questions
of the audience,
so I want you guys to start
thinking about questions.
And we have two
microphones over here.
10 minutes roughly.
But let's shift gears and give
you a bit of context here.
Obviously, three
weeks out from today,
we have the US elections.
I would argue one of the
biggest elections in the world.
And it was actually one
year ago, a good year ago,
when I moved to the US.
I wasn't really into politics.
But I developed a weird
fascination-- and my colleagues
here can definitely prove that--
for this political landscape
here, how the media plays
into it, the general process.
So I know that definitely,
some of my friends
are tuning in from Europe.
So people who are
not from the US
and not familiar with
this entire election
process right now, and let's
say the past 12 to 15 months,
do you mind giving us a synopsis
of what happened, 15 months
to today?
And I know we have 10 minutes.
And that will give us
a good idea, basically,
what the perspective of TYT
is and how you basically
run your shows.
CENK UYGUR: Yeah.
JOE: Take your time.
CENK UYGUR: Yeah, so it's funny
you say 15 months, because I
think right around
15 months ago,
I made a bet that
Donald Trump would
win the Republican primary.
And that's probably
inappropriate,
but we get to make
our own rules.
And at the time, people were
like, you're crazy, man.
Of course he's not going to win.
That's nuts.
He's a clown.
Right?
But what people are
missing and what
we can see because we
have outsider perspective
is people are really,
really mad at the system.
And so out in the
country in America,
they are losing their jobs.
They've got no
wage growth at all.
And even if they hung
on to their jobs,
they can't get their son
or their daughter the job
that they used to have.
And a lot of them are
working at Walmart.
And so they used to have
a decent paying job.
They don't anymore.
Then they need to
go on food stamps
to be able to live because
they're getting minimum wage.
They're angry, man.
And in their mind, they
played by the rules.
You told me to go to school.
I went to school.
You told me to work hard.
I worked hard.
And here I am at fricking
Walmart, and I got no hope.
And somebody online said
this analogy, and it's true.
They want to throw a brick
through the establishment's
window.
And that brick happens to
take the form of Donald Trump.
And their anger is misdirected.
So I talk to Republicans
all the time,
and I think I've done a
fair job of converting
a lot of Republicans
into progressives.
And it's because I
ask them, OK, you're
getting screwed by the system.
I think you're right.
I can prove to you
how you're right.
Now who do you
think did it to you?
The most powerless
people in the country?
The Mexican immigrant that
just crossed the border that
has no power at all?
Or the most powerful
people in the country?
Well, come on,
that's a no-brainer.
You know the real answer.
It's the most powerful
people in the country.
And they have that sense
too, like, ah, the powerful
are screwing me.
But the Republican Party keeps
telling them, no, no, no,
look away, look away.
It's the Muslims.
What Muslims?
They're worried about
Sharia law in Oklahoma.
It's a weird, blind
rage because they're
mad about what's going
on in their lives.
So even they don't
believe it's really
black people's faults, or
Mexicans' faults, or Muslims'
faults.
But they feel like, I gotta
have somebody underneath me
because I'm working at Walmart,
and I'm dying over here.
And I gotta feel
better about myself.
And Trump tells me it's the
Mexicans and the Muslims.
Great, that's what
I want to hear.
But really, what you should
hear is, no, your gut was right.
They did rig the system.
So for example, corporate
taxes used to be about 35%
of all the taxes in America.
It's now down to about 9%.
The payroll tax--
which is actually
the most regressive tax, the
one that not only the poor
and the middle class
pay, but it's capped,
the rich don't even pay it
after a certain amount--
that has increased to a much
larger piece of the tax pie.
They shifted the tax
burden from corporations
onto regular people.
That is one of dozens of
examples I can give you.
Because the Supreme
Court allowed bribery.
They said, oh, you can
give campaign donations
to politicians.
You can give money to Super
PACs, independent expenditures.
Well, that's bribery
by a different name.
And everybody on TV goes, no
bribery, I don't see bribery,
I don't see any evil,
I don't hear any evil.
Because where does it go?
In the old days, $4 billion in
an election cycle like this one
goes straight into
TV advertising.
I say old days, that's today.
I think it's changing now
because of digital advertising,
so soon, we'll get corrupted.
You can look forward to that.
But in all honesty, we have
to be on the lookout for that,
and you have to
be aware of that,
and you have to see the
trends that are coming.
And so in that system where they
were allowed to just give money
to politicians, and
then, of course,
they're going to get
back whatever they want.
You give somebody
a million dollars,
they work for you,
that's the reality.
And so I want to tell
those voters that
are angry out
there, whether it's
Republicans or Democrats,
focus your anger in a way that
is constructive.
And it's not personal.
Hillary Clinton
is not a monster.
She doesn't smell of sulfur.
That's a theory going around.
She doesn't have a body double.
She doesn't have dementia.
If she has dementia,
why is she killing
Donald Trump in the debates?
I know, low bar,
low bar, but still.
And directing it in the right
way is to fix the system.
It's not to be angry at
Hillary Clinton, or Jeb Bush,
or even Donald Trump,
or Mexicans, or Muslims.
It's to say, hey, I think
maybe we could do this a better
way, the way we used
to do it for about 40,
50 years in this
country after FDR,
which is we actually have
representatives representing
us.
It's this crazy idea
called democracy.
And if we get back to democracy
and free and fair elections,
I think this sorts itself out.
And then you'll be
shocked at how much better
our representatives are.
In this corrupt system,
what do we have?
We have Hillary Clinton,
which I think a lot of people
would argue, is the
corrupted, and Donald Trump,
who is the corruptor.
He brags about it.
In the Republican primaries,
he said, I bought all you guys.
I paid you, and you did
whatever I told you to do.
It's true.
In New York, he
paid Alan Hevesi,
who later went to jail
for corruption, $45,000,
and he got back $150
million tax break.
If you allow that
system, they're
going to do that all day long.
I'd do it.
Who wouldn't give $45,000 to
get a return of $150 million?
So the correct thing
is don't vote for Trump
because you're mad, and he's got
you convinced that somebody's
lower than you.
Don't settle.
In the case of Hillary
Clinton, oh, she
won, I bet she'll fix things.
I got bad news for you.
So fight through activism,
through new media,
through all of this, to
get to the real change
that the system needs so we
can get back to democracy.
JOE: Yeah, you're doing it on
one side with your channel,
but I know you're also
doing it with Wolf PAC.
Can you just share a little?
CENK UYGUR: Sure.
So Wolf PAC is a
super PAC I started
to defeat all other super PACs.
I hear that's impossible,
but I'm kind of
in the impossible business.
So I also heard it was
impossible to beat CNN when
I started in my living room.
So we've been there before.
And so what Wolf PAC
does is it acknowledges
that our founding fathers
were revolutionaries,
which is obvious.
And they built a revolutionary
document, the Constitution.
They said the revolution is
this thing called amendments.
So you don't have
to pick up a gun
like we did, you amend this
document as you go along.
You're supposed to.
And we'll give you two ways
to do it because we really,
really believe in it, because
we're revolutionaries.
One way is Congress calls for
an amendment, 2/3 of Congress.
But they said, at
some point-- and it's
in the Federalist Papers--
they say, at some point,
Congress will get too
corrupt, so we're going
to give you a second option.
2/3 of the states can
call for a convention
specifically for an amendment.
And then, no matter what, 3/4
of the states have to ratify it.
Don't get me wrong,
the US Constitution
is the hardest
constitution to amend.
It is not an easy process.
But every generation of
Americans has done it.
You know what was
really impossible?
How in the world can
women get the right
to vote when they don't
have the right to vote?
That was impossible.
And they did it.
That's the 19th Amendment.
So we have a
relatively easy job.
About 90% of the
country agrees with us
that money is
corrupting politics.
Republicans agree.
Democrats agree.
Libertarians agree.
Everybody agrees, money
is corrupting politics.
When we get that amendment, they
will turn around and go, oh,
come on.
You shouldn't even
get credit for that.
That was so easy.
That was inevitable.
You had the whole
country behind you.
And so that's what our job is.
We're going to go to
the states, and we're
going to get 2/3 of them
to call for a convention.
In that convention, we're going
to discuss election reform.
There will be
conservative ideals,
liberal ideas, every kind
of idea you can have.
And out of that commission, we
will come up with an amendment.
And then we'll bring
it to the states.
And 3/4 of it will ratify it.
And we'll fix this system.
That's what we're doing.
[APPLAUSE]
JOE: I heard you saying,
also, you're happy to die poor
and broke, but if
you get this through,
that would be the
achievement of your life.
CENK UYGUR: I would
prefer not to.
No, in all seriousness,
look, sure, material comforts
are great.
And I'm not a hippie
that's like, oh, man,
I could live on granola
the rest of my life.
I would rather not.
I like food.
But I think of the
Ben Franklin test.
So Benjamin Franklin was running
a local paper in Philadelphia.
Somebody comes up to him and
offers him a lot of money
to run an ad for, I think
it might have literally
been snake oil.
And he knows it's not
the right thing to do.
He knows the product's bad.
He says, I'm going to get
back to you in a week.
And for a week, he sleeps on the
floor, and he eats only bread
and drinks only water.
He comes back to him
and says, no thank you.
I'm not going to take that.
I could do that.
So that's the model we use.
So if it turns out I
gotta sleep on the floor,
and eat bread and drink water,
but we get that amendment,
I will take that in a second.
Because you know why?
It's not because I'm a great
guy or anything like that.
It's that fulfillment
is a hell of a drug.
And it feels so good.
And if you actually give
back, and you actually
get something accomplished
that lasts for a long time
and that actually
helps people, it's
the best feeling in the world.
So that's why all the luxuries
and stuff couldn't possibly
compete with that feeling.
I can't imagine
how good it would
feel to pass the 20th
Amendment and actually get
free and fair elections back.
Be the best feeling
in the world.
JOE: Cool.
All right, so we
have 15 minutes left,
and we open up the
floor to questions.
I see one, two people already.
We also have a Dory, our
internal questionnaire tool,
so we have a few
questions there.
CENK UYGUR: Questions
from the internet,
I would have never expected.
AUDIENCE: So first, I'll
say thank you for coming.
Second, I'll say
I've sat next to Joey
since he came to the US.
And in this tornado of whatever
we're going through right now,
and I'm really happy he's had
voices like yours to listen to,
because if he only listened
to the traditional voices,
he'd be as confused
as the rest of us.
The question pertains to
the earlier part of the chat
where you're talking
about traditional media
and traditional companies.
You've worked there.
You know what their stock is.
Do they see you coming?
When you think of the
taxi companies in Chicago,
you ask a lot of
these drivers, they
didn't see Uber coming
from a mile away.
And all of a sudden,
boom, they're here.
Do you think CNN, Fox,
do they see you coming?
CENK UYGUR: Mm-hmm.
So that's a great question.
They certainly didn't before.
So some of you know the
story, some of you don't.
I'll do a super
quick version of it.
At MSNBC, I didn't
follow the rules.
They literally told me to act
more like the establishment,
and they kept
telling me, hey, you
gotta root for the home team.
I'm like, the home team's the
audience, what do you mean?
And they meant the
Democratic Party.
And so they're a part
of the establishment.
And at some point, they
got a sense this guy is not
going to play ball.
He's annoying us.
We're going to move him to
the weekends, from 6 o'clock
at night, we're going to
move him to the weekends,
but we're going
to double salary.
And they thought, well, of
course he's going to take it.
One, we doubled his salary.
Two, where the hell
else would he go?
Because in the old days,
there was nowhere to go.
If you're an MSNBC
anchor, you're
not going to go to Fox News.
Likely, CNN won't take you.
Where are you going?
You're going back to Milwaukee?
And so that's a choice that
no one's ever said no to.
And I did, not because,
again, I'm a great guy,
but because I know the potential
of online news and our company.
And for me, that
was a no-brainer.
No, I'm going to go
tell my audience what's
actually happening.
And they were like, what?
Because they didn't see
the audience coming.
For them, they're
like, oh, that was
that cute little
thing you did to get
onto the real television.
For me, television is
marketing for my real audience,
which is online.
And so back then, it totally
took them by surprise.
They thought it was the
craziest thing they'd ever seen.
These days, it's a
little different.
I was at the
Brooklyn debate, one
of the last debates for Bernie
Sanders and Hillary Clinton.
And I ran into someone
on CNN's digital team--
I'll leave our their
names-- but he said,
oh, first thing we check
when the comScore comes out
is Young Turks.
Because we're number one
in half of the demos,
they're number one in half the
demos, and we're number two.
And they're number
two on each of those.
So they see us now.
But those monoliths are-- I
mean, those giant companies.
They're not monoliths,
I should say.
At CNN, there's a million
people in the building.
So some of the anchors come up
and yell at me in the streets,
like, I saw what
you said about me.
That's not fair.
Some of the other anchors
are like, what is a computer?
Some of the executives
are like, Jesus Christ,
how the hell is TYT beating us?
Some of the executives
are like, who are you?
So right now, it's a mix.
I think at some
point, as they're
shuttering the
windows and the doors,
they're going to be like, oh,
we should've seen them coming.
And final thing,
like I said earlier,
even if they see us coming,
they can't move the ship.
They're too used to making
money in the old way.
Some folks in media-- again,
I'll leave out the names--
are actually forward thinking.
Really.
Here, I'll say it.
ABC, more forward thinking
than the other old media,
much more so.
But I don't know that they
can move the ship either.
They're like, yeah, we see
the handwriting on the wall,
but-- [GRUNT] Can't move it.
Because what are
they going to do?
They're going to take
away the prompters?
I told them to take
away the prompters.
They're not going
to take that away.
Are they going to be
objective rather than neutral?
Neutral is he said, she said.
Democrats say this,
Republicans say this.
I'm super safe.
I didn't offend anyone.
Objective is, yeah, Democrats
say this, Republicans say that.
And here's what's reality.
And so they can't do it.
They can't say here's reality.
These guys are wrong.
On TV, that is almost-- you'll
get fired for saying it.
So they can't move the
ship, and they're doomed.
JOE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, first,
thanks for coming.
My question is I'd love to
hear more of your thoughts
on commenting and
discussion in general.
So what I found
really fascinating
with The Young Turks is it's
not just people consuming news,
they're also getting
on discussing it.
And what's particularly
interesting
about in the digital
age, you can do that.
You connect people throughout
the world on the same topic.
And so I'm curious to hear
what your thoughts are
on the next step of
engaging your audience,
either from a YouTube product
design standpoint of how
YouTube handles comments, or
maybe any other thoughts you
might have on engaging your
audience so they go out
and look at their
communities around them.
CENK UYGUR: Yeah, so
that's a great question
because there is a
particular problem there
that is hard to fix.
But you guys are smart, so you
might be able to figure it out
in a way that, certainly,
tech wise, we couldn't.
So as I described, we had this
wonderful symbiotic relation
with the audience.
We're getting
feedback from them.
And they're also our editors.
So I'll give you a
concrete example there.
Back in the '08 election,
John McCain was in some place,
and they chopped up his
speech in a local news outlet,
and they put it up.
We took it from the local
news outlet, we played it,
and we made commentary on it.
And people that were there,
because it's the internet,
people were in the room when
John McCain was speaking.
They said, no, no, no,
that's totally unfair.
You guys took John
McCain out of context.
And so we went back and
found the full tape,
and it turns out the local
news station had chopped it
in a way that was totally
unfair to John McCain.
So we came back, and we
said, thank you, guys.
Great job on editing.
It turns out this
is the full context.
And we didn't know,
but now we do, and so
that was unfair to John
McCain, and here's the reality.
So that was the good old days.
Today, there's
still some of that,
and I still--
people are amazed--
but I actually scroll
through the YouTube
comments a decent amount.
1,600 comments per video.
We do 10 videos a day on
just "The Young Turks,"
let alone all the
other network shows.
Obviously, I don't read
them all, but I skim.
Because if you listen
to any one commenter
and change your product
based on that, you're nuts.
But if 80% of the
commenters agree,
they're probably onto something.
And so you've gotta have that
umbilical cord between them.
So the problem is the trolls,
and everybody knows this.
And they come in, and
they've figured out a way
to be the first
page in every video.
They're so obsessed.
They've made a
living out of this.
And they're wherever they are--
[CLEARS THROAT]
I was going to say
they're in their basement,
but that's derogatory.
I like that I'm so
liberal, I'm worried
about being derogatory
towards trolls.
Anyway, I just want an
open flow of conversation
so I get something out
of it, the audience
gets something out of it.
And the first page
of every video
isn't, ah, Cenk is overweight!
OK.
I don't know, can I curse?
JOE: Yeah, sure.
CENK UYGUR: Yeah,
no shit, Sherlock.
We know that.
And you put that on a
thousand other videos.
And the guys watching,
they have eyes.
They know I'm fat.
So let's move on.
You're brown!
No shit, Sherlock.
So that's a slight issue.
I think we can get
past that issue,
but we gotta work on that.
JOE: Another
question over there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thanks for being here.
Earlier today, you talked about
the Davids and the Goliaths.
So you said that
the Goliaths are
the CNNs and the MSNBCs of the
world, and you are the David.
And so I have no doubt that
in the not so distant future,
the David will
overcome the Goliath.
However, the great thing
about digital platforms
such as YouTube is that it
allows any David to pop up.
The barrier to entry is minimal.
You just need a camera.
So as you are
overcoming the Goliaths,
are you concerned about
all the other Davids
that are popping up?
And what differentiates
you from the other Davids?
And that's it.
CENK UYGUR: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So when people ask me,
who is my competition?
Right now, that's
a funny question.
So yes, old media
as competition.
But I think that they
are in such dire straits,
that I think that 5,
10 years down the road,
I don't think
that's a real issue.
And I don't think
they're real competition.
There are some new media
folks that are working hard,
and they've got
their own models.
But I don't think that they
have the kind of camp fire
that we've set up.
I think they've got a
good tech solution for how
to get people to watch 30
second videos on Facebook,
and bless their hearts, but I
don't think that's sustainable.
Look, I'll give you
perspective on that too.
For example, Pluto
is a platform that's
doing really well on OTT.
And it just came
up out of nowhere,
and so I don't know that we
had high expectations for it,
but all of a sudden, big
revenue's starting to come in.
And I said, Jesus,
on YouTube, I get it.
We have hundreds of
millions of views.
On Pluto, not so many.
Why are we getting
this size a check?
Turns out, average viewing
time is 90 minutes for us,
which is unheard of in
digital, 90 minutes average.
So I don't think a lot of
the current digital media
companies are built for that,
and I think in the OTT world,
we're in great shape.
So who's my real competition?
It's a kid in Nebraska.
And I don't know
what his name is.
And I don't know how
he's going to do it.
But at some point, we'll
probably get Omar'd too.
For those of you who
watch "The Wire,"
watch out for the little guys.
They're going to Omar
you at some point.
AUDIENCE: Spoiler alert.
CENK UYGUR: Sorry,
that's a good point.
And so I am fully aware that
in a couple of years maybe,
we're going to be Goliath.
So we've got to look
out for the slingshots
and don't be so cocky about your
giant sword, and your shields,
and all that.
We haven't gotten there yet.
We're still David.
Again, in the new
paradigm, David
is the favorite,
not the underdog.
And at some point, we will
have a large enough size
that I gotta look out for all
the little David's coming out
of Nebraska, and Mumbai, and
Shanghai, and all those places.
But you know what?
I welcome that, because
our point wasn't just so
that we could win and
be the top company.
Our point was to
change the media.
And if we have
changed the media,
and they're all copying
us, then the audience wins.
So I'm super happy about
that state of affairs
if we get there.
JOE: Thank you.
The time is running
against us, but are we
cool with one more question?
OK.
One more question then.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it
can be a quick one
because it's actually a build on
something that Lauren mentioned
that you built on.
You talked about your business
and where you see it scaling,
which I thought was
really fascinating.
But you also mentioned
we could become Goliath,
and as long as we're delivering
things in the right way,
the audience wins.
I believe that.
But when you think
about the pitfalls
and organizational issues that
have happened with large news
organizations, how
do you, as a leader,
stay true to your values
throughout your company
and continue to instill
that from the top
down without
influencing, ultimately,
what comes out in your news?
CENK UYGUR: Yeah, you're right.
It's a matter of culture.
And so the culture is more being
open-minded than anything else.
And so our critics think that,
oh, you guys are just lefties,
or you just have
this point of view.
That isn't true.
We're fact-based, and we
believe in a range of opinion.
I would have more
conservatives on if I
thought they were being honest.
And lately, with
libertarians, we
are finding more and
more honest libertarians,
so I'd like to engage
them more and get them
more in the conversation.
But what I mean by honest is
you get a Republican guy who's
used to being on
TV, he will hit you
with talking point after
talking point, some of them
provided by ExxonMobil, some
of them provided by the NRA.
It's like, ugh, you're
not a human being.
You're a talking point machine.
Get off my air.
It's annoying.
Nobody is interested in that.
Yada yada.
But if you've got real
honest conversation--
so within our company, this
election was trying, man.
It frayed a lot of our
internal relationships,
because some are
in the Bernie camp,
some are in the Stein camp,
some are in the Clinton camp.
Some hate everything that's
going on, and yada yada.
And we started banging
heads sometimes.
We're still doing it, three
weeks out from the election.
And at some point, people come
and whisper to me, hey, hey,
we shouldn't let that guy
do as much as he does.
No, no, no, that guy.
And no, the answer is we
have got to be the forum.
So we're going to put
all that out there.
We're going to let
the audience decide.
I want the strongest voices
in all those different camps
so that the audience
can get informed,
have a variety of opinion.
And so it's my job to
keep that culture going
of open-mindedness.
I think just the other day,
somebody convinced me on air,
which, in TV,
when's the last time
you saw someone go, oh, wait
a minute, that's a good point.
You're right.
I change my mind.
[LAUGH]
That happens on The
Young Turks all the time.
It's usually me.
So the culture is
open-mindedness and making sure
that audience is informed
through that conversation.
JOE: I think that's a
great closing remark.
And please join in in giving
Cenk a warm Google Chicago
applause for being here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CENK UYGUR: Thank you, Joe.
OK.
JOE: For those of you who would
like to meet Cenk and his team,
who is sitting
somewhere [INAUDIBLE],
we are in Hyde Park
for a meet-and-greet.
[MUSIC PLAYING]